>> Good morning.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Morning.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Morning.
Did you guys have a
great tour this morning
of Baseball Americana?
>> Yes.
>> Sasha Dowdy: That was the
fastest self-guided exhibit,
right [laughs]?
You had 15 minutes.
I hope you had some
favorite parts.
Did you see stories of
some unexpected people
in the baseball exhibit?
And I know you only had 15
minutes, so the good news is
that you can keep exploring
this exhibit online.
You can go to loc.gov and
check out Baseball Americana,
and you can see so
many things online.
You can take a closer look.
You can engage with the
stories a little bit closer
and check it out some more.
So, today's program
is really special,
because one of the
stories we have
in the exhibit is
coming alive right
in front of you [laughter].
We have the story
of a very special,
very interesting baseball player
Mamie-- nicknamed "Peanut"--
Johnson, and you will hear
about this pioneer player
from the author of her
biography, Michelle Y. Green.
Mrs. Green is a storyteller.
She went to school to learn
how to tell people stories.
She teaches others
how to tell stories,
and she has published a
lot of stories she told
about people in her life.
She writes a children's book
series called "Willie Pearl,"
and that's about
her mother living
in the Depression era [laughs].
And, also, here she is,
the protagonist [laughter].
And Michelle Y. Green also
wrote the biography called
"A Strong Right Arm,"
which is about the hero
of the story you're
going to hear today.
And that's A Strong Right Arm,
the story of Mamie
Peanut Johnson,
which was published in 2002.
So, the story is actually
going into the next step
of a book's evolution
that happens sometimes,
and it's going to
become a movie.
And the movie is called
"Throw Like a Girl," [laughs]
and the production is starting
in February of next year.
So, that would be
really cool to see how.
>> Right.
>> Your friendships evolve
into stories that millions
of people can participate in.
So, no more delays.
Let's welcome Michelle
Y. Green, everybody.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I like to walk around.
I have a Fitbit, you see.
It counts my steps.
I'll sit down when I read,
but right now I'm
going to walk around.
What was your favorite
part of the exhibit?
I talked with this
young man, earlier.
Let's hear from some
of the women.
>> [Inaudible] microphone
so we can hear the kids.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Oh.
All right, [laughs] okay.
Anybody? Yes.
>> I liked the handwritten
things,
and I also liked the
little pocketbook.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Okay.
Great. Anybody else
want to chime in?
This is interactive.
You can talk to me, and
I'll talk back to you.
Go ahead.
>> I liked to see the dresses
that women would have
wear for baseball.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Yes, we're going to talk
about a woman ballplayer this
morning named Mamie Peanut
Johnson, and guess
what the best part is?
She was from Washington D.C.
She could walk to the Library
of Congress anytime
she wanted to.
She passed away in February,
sadly, but her legacy,
her story, still remains.
They have a Little League
team named after her,
Mamie Peanut Johnson team.
And they went all the way to
the championships this year.
They didn't win it.
My bad. They didn't win it,
but they tried their best.
There's a playground named
after Mamie Peanut Johnson
in Washington D.C.,
and there's a mural,
a big painting of
her on the wall.
And I like to think that
something in my discovery
of Mamie led to her
wonderful success.
We got a question
over here, a comment?
>> I like the part where you
could, like, feel how, like,
different the balls were then
and how they are
now and the gloves.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Baseballs?
I have a very old baseball.
Look at this.
And a very little mitt.
They called her "Peanut," but
she wasn't that small [laughs].
This is a prop that
someone gave me.
Okay, before I start talking
about Mamie, I want to talk
about what it's like to
be a real live author.
How many of you have
met an author before?
Been to a book signing?
Good. A lot of you.
Well, let me pull the
curtain back a little bit
and tell you what it's like
to be a real, live author.
Guess what I had for
breakfast this morning?
Cereal and juice [laughs].
You see, not all
authors are famous
like J.K. Rowling
and people like that.
We live right in
your neighborhood.
I live-- on a good day--
about an hour from here
in a little town called
Upper Marlboro, Maryland,
and my family is here.
Let me introduce
the rest of them.
There's my husband,
Oliver Green.
He's from Baltimore.
Unfortunately, the Orioles
didn't do too well this
year [laughs].
As a matter of fact, I
think they had the worst--
Were they the worst in baseball?
[Inaudible] In their
entire lives.
Now, I met this handsome man
at the University of Maryland
where I went to college, and
we married right after there.
And guess where he took
me on our very first date?
>> The Library of Congress?
>> No, not the Library
of Congress [laughter].
That's a good guess.
Actually, we might have
gotten married sooner
if he had taken me to
the library [laughs].
But we went to Baltimore on
the bus from College Park
where I got my journalism
degree,
and we went to Memorial
Stadium, because he grew
up loving the Orioles.
He lived not far
from there, you see.
Unfortunately, I hadn't gotten
into baseball at that time.
So, we took the long
bus from the University
of Maryland to Memorial Park.
It was a night game.
And guess what happened?
It rained.
Not only did it rain, but
they had a game delay.
So, now I'm sitting
there with this stranger,
this handsome stranger, in the
rain watching a baseball game.
And then it stopped,
and we weren't
in the nice, cushy box seats.
We were up, way up, because
we were students, you know?
While there was a rain delay,
he taught me about baseball,
what the different pitches
were, what it means to steal.
I didn't know any
of those things.
We have two sons.
One is Brian.
He's a filmmaker
in Philadelphia.
The other is Evan.
He's a music producer and
a vocalist in Los Angeles.
But before that, both
of them played baseball.
They started out very
little as playing tee-ball.
Anybody here play tee-ball,
or baseball, softball?
Anything? Any ball?
Okay, [laughs] a few of you.
Good. Well, we forced
Brian to play.
We said, "Try it
for one season."
He hated it.
But Evan went on to play
baseball all the way
through to high school
in Upper Marlboro.
Now, sitting next to
him is Willie Pearl,
who waved at you before.
My very first book that I
wrote 20 years ago is called
"Willie Pearl."
How many of you think
you might would
like to be a writer one day?
Anybody? Are you journaling?
[Inaudible] You write
stuff down.
That's good.
Let me tell you the
secret of good writing.
Write what you know, and nobody
knows your family like you.
If you're stuck for
something to write,
write your family story,
the good and the bad.
Now, Willie Pearl has three
books in her series, and,
next to her, is-- You're
not going to believe this--
my bowling coach [laughter].
You see? I'm not good at
baseball, but I bowl pretty good
and so does Willie Pearl.
We went on tour together,
if you can believe that.
Once, I won a lot
of badges [laughs].
So, sitting next to her is Mark,
Mark Henson [assumed spelling]
from Prince Frederick, Maryland.
Mark, do you like baseball?
>> Yeah, I love it.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Loves it.
He loves all kind of sports.
They talk to one another every
night that the game is on.
Sitting next to Ollie
[assumed spelling] is a very
special friend.
Her name is Alexis
[assumed spelling].
Now, Alexis is the farthest
away from any of you.
She lives in Bermuda,
a little island.
It's beautiful there.
I started going there
when I was a child.
Our family went there a lot.
Alexis is here, and I think
she's kind of pretty [laughs].
Okay. She's also in school.
She's going to College
of Southern Maryland
in La Plata, Maryland.
And she's deciding
to be an accountant.
Yes? [Inaudible]
How do you spell it?
[Inaudible] It's
the same as yours.
Very good.
Maybe you're related [laughter].
Let me tell you a funny story.
This has nothing to do with
baseball, has everything
to do with Willie Pearl.
We like to share family stories.
By the way-- Can I tell them?--
She's 94 years old [laughs].
So, for her 94th birthday,
my sister Adrienne [assumed
spelling] gave her one
of those fancy Alexa machines.
Do you know what they are?
You plug them in, and it talks
to you, tells you the weather,
the score of the ball game,
helps you remember things,
and plays your music.
Well, poor, Alexis,
when mom says "Alexa,
what's the weather like?"
Alexis comes running [laughs].
And sometimes she gets their
name mixed up [laughs].
Okay, back to being a writer.
My dad was a Tuskegee Airman.
Does anybody know what that is?
Tell me.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Yes.
Let's give him a hand.
My father, Eddie Lee
Young was a pilot,
a bombardier, and a navigator.
That's called triple rating,
and only two men, two black men
in history, were
ever triple rated.
And guess what book
I'm working on now?
It's called "High Flight,"
the story of Eddie Lee Young.
And guess where I'm
doing my research?
At the Library of Congress.
I come down here maybe once
a month and spend the day.
I wear comfortable shoes,
because it's a lot of walking.
But they have great photographs
here for you to research,
oral histories that
are recorded,
very knowledgeable people that
if you want to know anything,
they'll be glad to help you.
It's like that in
most libraries.
How many of you like
to go to the library?
Everybody.
Good. Well, because my
dad was in the air force,
we grew up all over the world.
I lived in Germany, Texas,
Maine, Mississippi, Canada,
and we travelled
all over the place.
I got my first love of writing
when I was in the fifth grade.
Now, many of you-- Are
you in the fourth grade?
>> Fifth grade.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
You're in the fifth grade.
I knew I wanted to be a
writer from the fifth grade.
My mom still has my
report card that says
that I was a good
writer [laughs],
so I started writing family
stories when I was young.
I didn't get published
until I got out of college,
but I love writing, and I
love mentoring young writers.
Let me get back to the
first rule of writing,
which is "Write what you know."
So, it's no secret that when I
wrote my first children's book,
I wrote it about Willie Pearl.
That's her real name,
Willie Pearl,
who grew up in the
mountains of Kentucky.
And there are three
books of that series.
Now, what does it take
to be a good writer?
What do you think?
What are some things that
you think make a good writer?
>> Creativity.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Creativity.
That's number one.
What else?
>> Knowledge.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Knowledge.
That goes with research.
I'll talk about that
in a minute.
Anything else?
It takes something to
write with, doesn't it?
>> A pencil.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
A pencil, a pen,
a crayon, a laptop, a journal.
How many of you have
access to computers?
I figured so.
Okay, all of you.
So, you have no excuse.
You can get on the internet
and do your research there.
You can come to the
Library of Congress.
You can come to your
branch library and find
out all the stuff that you
do need to know [laughter].
I wrote a little book
called "Oscar Invincible."
I'm reworking it now.
I wrote it for children.
Now I'm writing it for adults.
Oscar Micheaux was a slave.
His family were slaves.
He was a farmer in
Kansas, and then he went
on to be a home setter
in South Dakota.
But the thing that people don't
know about Oscar Micheaux is
that he was a filmmaker.
He lived in a little
soddy out in the middle
of nowhere South Dakota.
He bought himself a
little pot of land.
He was a black man.
Everybody thought he was weird.
He built himself a house out
of sod, and he was lonely.
He had no friends in that little
town of Gregory, South Dakota.
So, what did he do?
He started writing.
He wrote five novels.
And then when he couldn't
get them published,
guess what he did?
He published them himself.
Way back in the 1920s.
People are self-publishing
now, so you don't have to wait
for a publisher to get
your works published.
You can go on the internet and
self-publish through Amazon.
You don't have to be published.
You can write in a
journal and share it
with your friends and family.
The important thing for a
writer is to keep at it.
Those of us who do it
for a living like I do,
we try to write 500 words a
day, and that's not a lot.
That's like one page.
So, if you want to be a
writer, the first thing
to do is write [laughs].
You got to write.
Keep at it.
And don't worry about proper
grammar, proper spelling.
The first time you do something
it's called a "first draft."
Just write out whatever
is on your mind.
There's something
called morning pages.
When you first get up and the
creativity is just flowing.
Before you get ready for
school, before you get ready
to do all your chores and
all that, take a few minutes
to write what's on your mind.
There's something about sleep
that brings the imagination up.
Well, this morning, I was up
at 4 o'clock in the morning.
Can you believe that [laughs]?
Usually, I get up
at a quarter to six.
And before I have breakfast
or anything, I go to my laptop
or the journal beside my
bed, if I decide to sleep
in a little bit, and I just
write whatever comes to mind.
I'm not worried about grammar.
I'm not worried about
punctuation.
I'm not worried.
That's just for me.
It's not for anybody
else to see.
It's kind of like a diary.
Now, Alexis keeps
a wonderful diary.
She let me read some
of it one time.
She's an aspiring writer.
That means she wants
to be a writer, too.
I think that's terrific.
But when I was in the
fifth grade, we were living
in Ramstein, Germany,
an air force base,
and I had this wonderful
teacher, Mrs. Raoule [phonetic].
Mrs. Raoule would read
to us an hour every day.
Can you believe it?
We've come back from
the cafeteria all full
of good cafeteria food
[laughs], and we'd be all comfy,
cozy in the classroom.
And guess what she would read?
Little House on the Prairie.
How many of you know that book?
Oh, great [laughs].
And it's a TV show, too,
but I love the books.
So, she would read
to us after lunch.
And sometimes we'd put
our head on our desk
and sleep a little
bit or nod off.
But when I kept hearing Laura
Ingalls Wilder all the time,
when I started to write
Willie Pearl, guess what?
It sounded a lot like
Laura Ingalls Wilder.
She was my role model.
Does anybody know what the
word "muse" means, M-U-S-E?
Anybody? Wanna take
a stab at it?
What's a muse?
>> Like a maze.
>> Michelle Y. Green: A what?
[Inaudible] A maid?
>> A maze.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Oh, a maze?
I thought you said, "a maid."
I'd love to have
a maid [laughs].
A maze? No, a muse is a
person, like a role model,
that inspires you to write.
Like, I have a muse.
His name is-- Well,
it's not important,
but he's a famous musician.
And when I sit down to write,
I like to write with music
in the background and
a good cup of coffee.
That's why I get up early.
So, that's what the
writing life is.
It's getting up, writing
whatever's on your mind.
And then if you have an
important story to tell,
to do the research and
do all kinds of research.
It's not just about going
to a library and digging
into the encyclopedias.
It's called experiencing
things, and that's going
to bring me right
around Peanut Johnson
and how this story happened.
Here's a picture of
Mamie and me in what used
to be the Negro league's
baseball shop in Mitchellville.
It's not there anymore.
It's a church now.
But before you know it, this
is how we became acquainted.
This is Mamie.
Everybody see her?
A real live person.
Well, I live in Upper
Marlboro, and my son,
Evan, was playing baseball.
He was just starting out.
He wasn't that good at it.
So, I was driving around,
doing my errands one Saturday,
and I pulled into a new store
to grand opening Negro
league's baseball.
Now, being a writer, I
was curious, instantly.
So, I went in.
I said, "Maybe I can find
a jersey, or a videotape,
or a book to help my little
Evan out play baseball better.
So, I walked to the store.
They had videos, books,
jerseys like this.
They had all kinds of stuff.
I went to a rack, and they
had jerseys like this,
and it said "Clowns" on it.
Well, I got interested.
And, not only that, they had
T-shirts that had this image
of a woman hurling a ball or
pitching a ball, and I thought,
"This is really exciting.
It said "Pitcher"
on it P-I-T-C-H-E-R,
pitcher, like a pitcher.
I said, "I got to know
more about this woman."
So, I bought the shirt.
I took it to the
register, and I said,
"I'd like to buy this shirt.
And he said, "Cash or credit?"
And I said, "Can
I write a check?"
[laughs]. So I wrote the
check, and then he said, "Well,
you know, the woman
Mamie Peanut Johnson is
in the store right
now, autographing.
Would you like to meet her?"
I said, "Oh my goodness, Mamie
is in the shop right now?"
It's the great opening.
They had other Negro league's
baseball players there.
So, I walked over with my
jersey, and I said, "Mamie,
would you sign my
jersey, please?"
And she signed it.
You can hardly see.
It says, "Indianapolis
Clowns, Mamie,
1953 and to 1955"
is when she played.
And I said to her, "I didn't
know there were female
ballplayers that were
African-American.
She said-- She likes to
use the word "honey"--
"Honey, there were three of
us, three women who played
in the professional Negro
league's black baseball.
And of the three, I'm the
only one still alive."
And the writer in me went,
"There's a story here" [laughs].
So, I sat down next to
her, and I said, "Mamie,
has anybody written your story?"
And she said to me, "Honey,
[laughs] I've been waiting
for someone to ask
me that question."
And I said, "Well, this is
your lucky day" [laughs].
We didn't start interviewing
right away, because I had
to get back to my children, but
I made an appointment with her
to start doing my research.
What's the first kind of
research you think I did?
I'm just meeting her
for the first time.
She's a living legend.
What kind of research did I do?
What process did I use?
[Inaudible] I asked
her her story, yes.
You had a comment?
The same thing.
It's called interviewing, right?
You've seen interviews.
You know what interviewing is.
That's when you talk
to someone to find
out more about their life.
So, if you're going to write
a story about your family,
or your grandparents, or your
famous rock star, or something,
you try to get an
interview with that person
and ask some questions.
When I wrote Willie Pearl,
I had a favorite cousin,
her younger brother called
"Johnny" [assumed spelling].
And Johnny would get up
very early in the morning
to make his coffee,
so I would join him.
He was a coalminer.
Her family were coalminers,
so they'd get
up early in the morning.
So, I would have
to get up at 4:00,
sit down with my Uncle Johnny,
and I had a little
tape recorder,
a little microcassette.
And you know what?
I would just ask him to talk,
talk about what was important
to him, what was on his
mind, what he liked to do.
So, I did the same
thing with Mamie.
So, if you're going
to interview someone,
always ask permission first.
But you'll find that most
people are willing to talk
about themselves, okay?
So, I sat down in the Negro
league's baseball shop
and started interviewing Mamie
while she was signing books,
signing baseballs, and so forth.
The next thing I had to
do, I had to learn how
to play baseball,
because she was a pitcher,
the only professional
woman pitcher who played
with a man's team
ever in history.
And I didn't know
much about baseball.
Evan was learning.
Ollie was helping him.
So, guess what I did?
I joined Evan's Little
League team [laughs].
Well, I didn't actually join.
I talked to the coaches, and
I said, "Could I, you know,
learn some stuff from you?
Like what?
Well, I need to know how
to throw the curve ball."
That was Mamie's favorite pitch.
He said, "Well, we
can teach you that."
This man was on her
team, Hank Aaron.
Maybe you've heard of him.
Very famous.
When she was with the
Indianapolis Clowns,
Hank Aaron was her teammate.
This guy, Satchel Paige,
okay, he taught her how
to throw the knuckleball.
This man, Satchel
Paige, was so talented.
He was very tall and skinny
like you can see here, okay?
But he had pitches that
were so unbelievable
that they gave them names.
They gave his pitches names.
They used to call him [laughs]
the "Chocolate Whizbang,"
because he would throw
a pitch, and it would go
so slow it would drop
right down on the plate.
No one could hit it.
And in the next pitch he
threw was so wild, so fast,
the call it the "bee
ball," because it was
so fast the batter
couldn't even see it.
Okay. Getting back to Mamie.
I worked out with Evan's team
for about a whole season.
And at the end of the year,
they had a special event
where the parents
would play the kids,
just a fun kind of a thing.
So, then I got to
actually take the field.
I was so excited.
I was going to be able to
show off what I learned:
hitting, running.
You know what the
coach said to me?
"Oh, here comes Michelle."
Parents, you have to throw
with your opposite hand,
because you have an
advantage over your kids.
So, if you're a right-hander,
you have to do everything
with your left hand.
If you bat right, you're
going to have to bat left.
And they said to
me, "Mrs. Green,
[laughs] you can use
your right hand."
I was so bad, but I had a ball.
And from Evan's coaches,
and from playing,
I got to experience baseball.
So, if you're writing about
something that you don't know,
try to experience it,
not just do interviews
and research in the library.
Try to experience it
so it becomes your own.
That's where the passion is.
It's something that you really
know that you want to express.
Okay, I toured around
with Mamie.
Wherever she went to
baseball trading cards.
We travelled all
around the area.
And then it took me-- guess
how long-- to write the book.
How long did it take for
me to do my research?
[Inaudible] Very good.
It took me three years [laughs].
And when I wrote about Oscar
Micheaux, it took longer
than that, because I had
to travel to South Dakota
to see his soddy and to Kansas
so interview his family.
So, writers often do
a lot of traveling.
We take a lot of photographs.
Now, the photographs
in this book--
And you'll see, because
everybody's getting a copy
of it and a baseball card.
[ Applause ]
Let me show you this.
It's called photo research.
So, I got to go to the archives
and, also, I got to ask Mamie
for her family pictures.
This is Mamie when
she was 12 years old.
Isn't she gorgeous?
You see that?
She went through her Bible and
pulled out old photographs.
There's one here of her mother.
Let me find it.
And her best friend.
Well, I can't find
it, but you'll see it
when you read the
book on your own.
Okay. So, research can mean
interviewing, going to places
like the Library of Congress,
the National Archives,
asking people what's
important to them,
experiencing whatever
you can for your own,
because it becomes
what you know.
And that makes for
very vivid writing.
Well, some of you
are saying, "Well,
I'm not that good in English."
In fact, I hate English.
That doesn't matter.
They have something called
"editors" that will help you
out with the small stuff.
Just write your story.
Start with your family.
Okay, so here's what I learned.
Mamie used to play baseball
in her grandmother's front
yard in South Carolina.
And they didn't even
have a real ball.
You know what they used?
A rock with sticky tape,
masking tape, a rock.
They didn't even
have a real bat.
They used a tree branch.
You read about this in the book.
They didn't have
nice white bases.
They had a broken pie plate
that they used for bases.
And her uncle she
called "Bones,"
who was just a little bit older
than she was, taught her how
to pitch, and she loved it.
Then her grandmother died
suddenly, and she had to move.
Her mother was living
in Washington D.C. Mamie was
staying with her grandmother.
She had to move from
place to place to place.
And everywhere she went,
she wanted to find out
"How can I play baseball here?"
She moved to Long
Branch, New Jersey--
New Jersey's not
that far from here--
and she lived with
her aunt and uncle.
There were no baseball
teams that girls could join,
and she didn't like softball.
How many of you have
played softball
and know what softball is?
Softball is kind
of like baseball,
only you pitch differently,
and the ball is really big.
She didn't like that.
She wanted to play hardball.
So, guess what Mamie did?
She went to a-- It was
an all white boys' team
and would watch them.
And they would ridicule her,
because she was a little black
girl, new to the community,
and she would watch
them from the fence.
She found out that they were
the Police Athletic League,
PAL League.
They still have them everywhere.
So, guess what she did?
She walked over to
the precinct house.
That's where all the law
enforcement people were,
and she said, "Excuse me, I
want to be on the PAL team."
And they said, "You're
kidding, right?"
She says, "No, I love baseball,
and there's no baseball for me.
I want to be on the PAL team."
And one officer said, "Well,
let me see what you can do."
So, he took her to the
back of the precinct house,
put a ball in her hand, and she
said, "Well, I like to pitch.
I'm good at hitting,
but I love to pitch."
He said, "Well, show me
your fastball, then."
And they played for about 20
minutes right in the backyard
of the precinct house.
And he said, "You know what?
You can join the team."
But having the coach say
she could join the team
wasn't enough.
She, actually, had [laughs]
try out with the boys.
Now, what do you think
that must have been like?
She was, like, 12
years old then.
And she shows up, and this
little red-haired boy started
ridiculing her until
she took to the mount.
And nobody could hit her.
[Laughs] Nobody could hit her.
So, she went on to play with
this boy's team and led them
to the championship
for two years.
Can you believe that?
At the age of 12.
Now, let me tell you how
she got the name "Peanut."
Well, Mamie was only 5 foot 2.
Willie Pearl is 5 foot 2?
[Laughs] So, when she stands
up later, you'll be able
to see how 5 foot 2--
I'm 5, 5 and a half.
So, Mamie was shorter than me,
and she signed her
first contract
when she was 16 years old.
She auditioned in Washington
D.C. at Banneker Field.
I went to Banneker Field
across from Howard University
and saw the field
where she played,
where she had her audition.
Mamie, she was a
wonderful thing.
She had a fine sense of
humor, a Southern drawl.
She called everybody
"Sugar" and "Honey."
She was really good to get along
with, and she told me stories
of what it was like to
travel with the men's team.
Now, remember, she
was the only woman
on a professional men's team
that toured all year round.
Her team was called the
"Indianapolis Clowns."
You see it on my hat.
You see it here.
In fact, I'll pass this
around so you can see it.
They were called the "Clowns,"
not because they
didn't play well.
Has anybody heard of the Harlem
Globetrotters basketball?
Well, these Indianapolis
Clowns were so talented that,
before the game would start,
they would warm up the crowd
by doing all kinds
of stunts and tricks,
like the Harlem Globetrotters
did.
That's why they were
called the "Clowns."
I said, "Didn't you
have trouble being
on a team called the 'Clowns?'
Didn't you feel ridiculous?"
She said, "Oh, no.
If you could see us play, you
could laugh all you wanted
to before the game started.
But once the game started,
we were dead serious
about what we did."
Indianapolis Clowns.
Let me talk a little
bit about her jersey.
By the way, this cover
was done by Kadir Nelson
when he was very young.
Now Kadir is famous, famous.
He does covers for
the The New Yorker.
Adults, if you've seen his
latest work, it's just awesome.
He does covers for The
New Yorker all the time.
When he first showed me, he
did it as a large painting,
about the size of that poster.
This was a large painting.
And when I went to New York
to see it for the first time,
I said, "Oh my goodness, I
can't believe my book is being
illustrated by this
talented person."
I showed it to Mamie.
You know what she said?
"Why are my feet so big?"
[laughter].
And the other thing.
You can see it here
a little closely.
She has a ponytail.
Well, when he first drew her,
because he'd never met her,
he drew it with just
her ball cap on.
And she said, "Oh, no.
My hair was long."
And it was long.
She kept it long until she died.
So, he had to add a little
ponytail stuck on there.
You can barely see it,
[laughs] but it's there.
And, yes, her feet do look big,
but that's his style [laughs].
She didn't like that very much.
Mamie would travel with the
boys' team, with the men,
24 sweaty men on a bus.
It wasn't like baseball
players today.
They got paid pennies a day.
It depended upon how many
people came to the game
and whether they won or lost.
If they won, they
got more money.
If they lost, the other
team got all the money.
They would play and go on
a bus from place to place,
especially in the South.
And during that time in the
1950s-- I was born in '54--
she was actually playing then.
I didn't know her--
African-Americans--
"Negroes" we were called then--
couldn't just eat anywhere.
Couldn't just sleep anywhere.
You've, probably, learned
that in your history classes
or social studies, right?
You know about Brown vs.
Board, things like that.
You look like a very
smart group.
So, she would travel
on this bus.
The bus was so old and rickety
that sometimes it
would break down.
They'd have to all get off
and push it to the next place.
Or they didn't have enough
money to buy gas to get
to the next place that
they were playing.
So, it wasn't like the glory
days now with Cal Ripken,
who just got married by
the way, from the Orioles.
He made a lot of money.
Who's watching the World
Series, by the way, anybody?
Who do you like?
[Inaudible] The Dodgers?
Oh. Well, you know, black
baseball has Dodgers.
Anybody else?
Anybody like Boston?
[Laughs] Well, I like Boston,
because Boston adopted this book
Strong Right Arm, one summer,
and used it as a part of their
special promotions for kids.
They gave away a lot of these
books, and Mamie got to go
up to Boston and throw out the
first pitch at a Boston game.
Before the Nationals were
a team in Washington D.C.,
when they were just
becoming a team
and they had their very first
game, the Washington Nationals.
Guess who was there?
Mamie, me, and my son Evan.
We sat right next to the mayor.
Can you believe that?
Before the Nationals became
the Washington Nationals.
You've seen their big
stadium, haven't you?
I went to a rock
concert there [laughter].
Saw the Eagles [laughter].
Getting back to baseball
[laughter].
Writers can be crazy people.
I said, "Mamie, tell me
about your uniforms."
She said, "Oh my goodness.
These uniforms."
This is an actual
replica, a copy,
of the kind of uniform
that Mamie wore.
And if you feel the hat, it's
made out of the same material.
It's wool.
Now they have synthetic fabrics,
polyester, cotton blends.
They're very comfortable.
How many of you own a jersey?
Maybe you've gone to baseball
game and gotten a jersey?
They're expensive,
aren't they [laughs]?
But they're very nice.
Well, back then,
they played in wool.
It was a natural
fabric, but it itched.
I said, "What was it like?
And if you see on the cover,
I just have the jersey on.
But they had wool pants
in the summertime.
Why do you think
they played in wool?
Anybody have an idea?
Any grownup have an idea?
What do you think?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Well, that's part of the reason.
Wool did get dirty.
It lasted a long time.
Wool lasts a long time.
It might itch, but
it doesn't wear
out like a cotton
jersey when you wash it.
And they're going to be fooling
around in the dirt all the time.
It's going to wear
very, very well.
And I said, "Well, okay."
That's what book is called
before it's published,
when it's typed up and
someone's editing it,
it's called a "manuscript".
When my editor saw the
manuscript, she said,
"It's not enough
to say it itched.
Tell us how it itched.
What did it feel like?"
And so I said, "It
itched like all get-out,
which is what we would
say in the South."
She said, "No, I
don't like that."
She said, "How about"-- and
we tried different things.
I took it back to Mamie.
She said, "It just
itched [laughs]."
So, that's how it appears in
the book when you read it.
It just itched.
You don't have to say
like, "It itched like this.
It itched like that."
It just itched, but
it was durable.
Now, ladies, I got to tell you.
How many of you have brothers?
Okay. Older brothers,
younger brothers?
Older brothers?
Okay. All the men cover
your ears [laughs].
No, not really.
Thank you.
She would be the only
woman on a bus with men.
Men can be disgusting at
times [laughs], especially,
if they played a game.
They're sweaty.
They're hot.
They like to blow off steam by
playing cards, maybe, you know,
drinking a little something
stronger than Coca-Cola.
And Mamie was right
in the middle of it.
Now, what do you think that
would happen when they had
to get ready to change their
uniforms or when they're
on the bus and had
to make a potty stop?
Keep in mind, they couldn't
go into the white bathrooms.
Mamie had to go in the bushes.
When you got to go, you've
got to go [laughter].
And when she changed her
uniform, all the men would have
to get off the bus so Mamie
could change into her uniform.
I said, "Well, Mamie, what
was it like playing with men?"
She said, "Honey,
[laughs] I loved it.
They treated me like a lady,
and they protected me."
And I got to meet some of
her old-timey baseball guys
in the baseball shop
and in other places.
And you know what?
They're just the
most polite people
that you ever want to meet.
Now, before I read a
part of the chapter,
do you have any questions
about baseball, about Mamie,
about women playing in sports?
There is another pitcher.
Her name is Ila Borders.
A few years back,
she was, actually,
pitching with a Minor
League way out in Colorado.
And we still don't have
any women baseball players
in a professional sense
in this country, do we?
But we have Olympians.
We have soccer players.
We have other women that
are doing wonderful,
wonderful things in sports.
Any questions for
me before I read?
Oh.
>> Did she ever get, like, booed
because she was the only woman?
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Did I ever get booed?
Did she ever get booed?
>> Yeah, at, like, a game.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Oh, yes.
There's a chapter in here.
It's one of my favorites.
I'm glad you brought that up.
She's a really good pitcher.
She could throw the fastball,
the knuckleball, the curveball--
all these different
kinds of pitches.
She was playing in the
championships once,
and this heavy hitter,
someone who's really,
really good, came
up to the plate.
And he started intimidating her.
This is how she got her name.
It's a good question, because
I forgot to tell you that.
He stood up there and he
said, "Ain't no peanut
of a woman gonna strike me out."
He was tall.
He was 6 feet something,
muscular.
He's in the book.
You'll see him.
Mamie, that's all the
motivation she needed.
She threw a few curveballs,
strike one.
A knuckleball, strike two.
Yes? [Inaudible]
I'm not telling you.
You have to read it for
yourself [laughter].
That's a way of saying my
memory's a little shot.
No.
No [laughs], you
read it for yourself.
It's, really, my
favorite chapter.
She struck him out one by one,
and she said, "Call me Peanut,"
and she adopted it
as her nickname.
Ballplayers are famous
for having nicknames,
and so was she, okay?
Other questions before I read?
About writing, about sports.
Oh, in the back.
Yes.
>> How long did she
play for with the boys?
>> Michelle Y. Green:
How long did she play?
>> Yeah.
>> Michelle Y. Green: She played
for three years, and they went
to the championship every
single year that she played.
A lot of people will tell
you the Negro leagues
weren't talented.
You've, probably, heard of
this man, Jackie Robinson?
He was the very first colored
player, the first Negro,
to cross over and play
for the white teams.
And after him, little by little,
they started letting
black talent go
into the Major Leagues.
And so all the good
players started going
to the white teams, and
the Negro Leagues died out,
because people would
want to pay good money
to see a black man play
on a white team even though
he was threatened with suicide
and death threats all the time.
He was a college educated man.
You should read Jackie's
[inaudible].
I got to meet his daughter once.
Mamie and I were on tour,
and we got to sign books
and baseballs with her.
Fascinating story.
Was there another question?
>> So, in the three years
that Mamie has played
and when they went
to the championship have
they won the championship?
>> Michelle Y. Green: Did
they win the championship?
>> Yes.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Yes, they did.
There were two other
women, eventually,
that played black
baseball: Connie, Stone,
and another lady [laughs].
They're in the book, too.
Their picture's in the book.
When I met Mamie, they
had long since passed.
Okay. Let me read
to you a little bit
of my favorite chapter called--
Oh, I was talking about the
talent in the Negro leagues.
After Jackie Robinson
crossed over,
many of the black
players started playing
on the white teams.
No women, though.
This chapter is called
"Carolina Summers."
Now, it's fall now.
Pretend like it was a few
weeks ago when it was really,
really hot instead of
cold like it is today.
I'm going to sit down now.
I'm just going to
read a part of it.
You can read the whole
thing for yourself.
Sometimes I read it
with Mamie's accent,
but I'm not going
to do that today.
I'm going to use my own voice.
Carolina Summers.
Summers in South
Carolina where I live
with my grandma Cendonia
Belton were almost hot
but not city hot.
In Ridgeway, South Carolina,
in 1945, the heat had room
to move around, to
swirl off the dust,
and bother the sweet gum trees.
It got carried around on
the backs of dragonflies
and dazzled the clothesline tea
towels into brilliant white.
It settled on screen doors.
It stuck to the back of necks.
"Summer was too hot for
baseball," Grandma said.
But every day, as soon as
she could [inaudible] away
from her watchful eye Leo,
and me, and the other kids
around would be out
in the yard to play.
Leo-- We called him "Bones"--
was my uncle but close enough
in age to be my big brother.
Here's that picture of her
grandmother Cendonia Belton
and Bones, her uncle,
from her family album.
We marked out the bases every
day, like we didn't already know
that the pie plate was
first, the broken piece
of flour pot the second, and
the large root about three feet
from the lilac bush was third.
And when we'd slide into home
plate, we'd always be sliding
over the smooth white
lid of a 5-gallon bucket
of King Cane sugar, the
sweetest in the South.
You see, they didn't
need real bases
and real baseballs and things.
They used their imagination.
I was 10, and it was
my job to get the ball.
For that, I didn't have to go to
no dry goods store 2 miles away
or to Thorntree School to beg.
No-legs Levy [assumed spelling],
our principal, for one--
That was his nickname,
"No-legs Levi."
All I had to do was find a nice
size rock and wrap it round
and round with sticky tape
until it had a good heft.
They let me get the ball,
because I was always
the one throwing it.
I loved everything
about baseball,
but it was pitching
I loved the best.
Oh, sure, I could run the
bases faster than a jackrabbit.
But nothing made me grin on
the inside like pitching.
I like the standing up tall.
The looking the other fellow
in the eye to size him
up for a changeup or a fastball.
And then the pitch.
And I didn't pitch
like a girl, either.
Bones made sure of that.
Not an underhanded fling of the
ball, but a surefire, windup,
coming-right-at-you pitch
smack dab over the plate.
One that let him know
I meant business,
one that could tear the bark
right off the tree branch the
other fellow was
using for a bat.
Grandma said that pitchers
mound was no place for a girl.
Even my best friend, Mary Alice
Quails [assumed spelling],
who was pretty and all
the boys liked her--
She didn't hold any
truck with baseball.
But baseball was what I liked.
The only thing better
was a package from home.
Ridgeway was where I
lived with grandma,
but my real home was Washington
D.C. Just about every month,
I'd get a package from my Mama.
There's a picture of
her beautiful mother.
I'd get a package from
my Mama who lived there
and worked hard to support me.
Skipping forward.
But Grandma's house in
Ridgeway was big enough
to hold all my dreams.
It had 18 rooms.
It sat on 81 acres.
It had fruit trees of every
kind: plums, peaches, pears,
running streams, and no fences.
Maybe I dreamed such big dreams
because there was plenty of room
to spread them out in
Ridgeway, room for them to run,
and stretch, and grow.
I remember thinking the city
was no place for big dreams.
They'd get all cramped
up and bent,
like trying to throw a
fastball with your arm cocked.
In my room, in Ridgeway, I could
look out into the night sky
and see starlight, a wide open
sky where my dreams could run.
Once, I saw a shooting star.
God must like baseball,
I imagine.
He's got a fastball
as good as mine.
And that's the end
of Carolina Summers.
[ Applause ]
Now, you might note
that the big is written
in what's called first person.
Who knows what first
person is, or who can guess?
Someone who hasn't
answered before.
>> It's, like, the
first person view, like,
your own view kind of,
like, that person's view.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Right, right.
You see, I travelled with Mamie
so much and got to know her
so much, she called
me her "daughter."
She adopted me, because,
everywhere she went,
I went to learn more about her.
We went to ballgames
together, practiced together.
She tried to show me how
to throw a curveball.
I said, "Don't waste
your time [laughs]."
But first person is
when the narrator,
the person who's
telling the story,
is talking in their own voice.
Instead of saying "She did
this," it would be "I did this."
Now, I wrote it in
first person, because,
when I sat down after all
the research that I did,
the first line that came to
me was in Mamie's own voice.
So, it's called a
biography, because it's really
about her life, but it
doesn't quite fit the mold
of a real biography,
because I used Mamie's voice,
her way of speaking.
It's gotten me in a little
bit of trouble, because,
when they categorize
it in libraries,
they don't know how
to categorize it.
Is it biography?
Is it fiction?
What is it?
Well, who cares?
It's a good read [laughs], and
you'll get a chance to read it.
You'd also see a baseball
that's of me in Mamie's clothes,
and there's a description
of the book on the back.
It's a trading card, and my
son Brian, the photographer,
took it right on my back deck.
So, see, we have families too,
and we do crazy things together.
What else can I tell you?
I have a website.
It's just my name .com,
michelleygreen.com, so, adults,
if you can remember,
it's user friendly.
It's got pictures of Mamie
on it, pictures of my family,
a video from my son, another
music video from my other son,
and a video about my
dad, a Tuskegee Airman.
Now, today, when I leave here,
I drive down to Fredericksburg,
Virginia to be in
a harvest festival.
I'm representing
the Tuskegee Airmen
in an exhibit there
for four days.
So, I told them "I'm coming
in a baseball uniform,
but I'll change into my Kathy's
[assumed spelling] once I get
there [laughs]."
So, if you're in town, or
if you're free, Saturday,
harvest festival, Shannon
Airport, and you'll learn
about Tuskegee Airmen.
They have a P-51,
which my father flew.
They have a panoramic
movie that's going
to describing those
kinds of things.
And like I said, I'm
writing his book.
It's called "High Flight."
There's another website
called highflight.academy,
but if you go to my website,
it'll link you directly
to the other website, as well.
Any more questions?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Excellent [inaudible].
>> My grandma was an
author, and she wrote a book
about my dad and uncle.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Great.
>> And she put it on Amazon.
>> Michelle Y. Green: On Amazon.
You see, when I was first
writing, there was no Amazon.
I lived in the dinosaur
age, by the way.
I have a little secret for you.
My birthday is coming
up, November 5.
Anybody want to take a guess?
How old am I going to be?
Don't hurt my feelings.
Remember, I have a
94-year old mother.
How old do you think I am?
Take a guess.
>> Sixty-seven [laughter]?
>> Michelle Y. Green: Actually,
you're not that far
off [laughs].
>> Sixty-two?
>> Michelle Y. Green: I'm 63.
I'll be 64 next month.
Congratulations.
Yes?
>> Sixty-five?
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Oh, he guessed 63.
I'm 63. I'll be 64
in a couple of weeks.
Yes?
>> My birthday's November 24.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Really?
Congratulations.
How old will you be, 67?
>> Ten.
>> Ten [laughter].
Okay. The same age Mamie was
when she started playing ball
in her grandmother's backyard.
Any other questions?
Adults? Oh, let me tell you
a little bit about the movie.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Back to Mamie's comment was
she's been waiting her whole
life for somebody to ask her.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Right.
>> What does she
think of the story?
I'm curious.
>> Michelle Y. Green: Oh,
that's a great question.
Once I got the research down,
the writing was really fast.
Once I got all the ideas, I
sat down, and I knocked it
out in a couple of weeks.
So, I took my manuscript
to Mamie and said,
"Would you please read this
before I send it off to my agent
to be published and
to be edited."
And you know what
she said to me?
"I don't want to read it.
I want to be surprised."
I said, "Mamie, [laughs] I
might have made some mistakes."
She said, "Honey, you know
me better than anybody.
I don't want to read
it until it comes out."
So, when the book finally
arrived in its little box.
The first books were
in hardback like this.
They don't make the hardbacks
anymore, only made paperbacks.
Thank goodness that they do.
Oh, by the way.
If you want to listen to
it, it's on audible.com.
They read the whole book in
Mamie's accent on Audible.
And by the way, Audible
is running a special now,
so you can get it for free.
So, ask your parents or your
caregivers to download it.
Your question again?
>> What Mamie thought
of the story.
>> Michelle Y. Green: So,
when the book came out,
you know what she did?
She cried.
And when we go out
on tour together,
they would introduce
her and introduce me,
she'd call me her "daughter."
And often, she would
just break down in tears.
My own mother does
that, too, sometimes.
I think she's crying
now [laughs].
That's, okay, you
can cry [laughs].
I cry all the time [laughs].
Now, let me tell you just
a bit about the movie.
It's called "Throw Like a Girl."
Where did that expression
come from do you think?
Anybody want to guess?
You. [Inaudible] Yes, when
a guy was making fun of her.
And you probably
have heard this.
You're just a girl.
What can you do?
You throw like a girl.
Well, we're proud to
throw like a girl.
If you can strike people
like Hank Baylis is the name.
Hank, if you can throw
people out like Hank Baylis,
I'd be glad to throw
as good as that.
Throw Like a Girl.
It won an award for best script
in last February,
this past year.
I got to go to New
York with my sister
and see the script
writer, a female,
Laurie Lahey [phonetic]
wrote the script.
It was her first time
doing a screenplay,
and she won an Athena
Award for best screenplay.
Now, they're in the middle
of casting it right now.
Can I drop a little nugget?
Guess who might be cast?
Octavia Spencer.
Do you know her?
She's a famous actress,
and there will be others.
So, keep your fingers crossed,
and I'll keep everybody in touch
with the Library of Congress.
Who knows?
We might need some extras to
sit in the crowd, you know?
We'll think about you.
So, it's introduction.
It's taken 10 years for
the film to come this far.
Three tries.
It's hard to get into films.
My son is a filmmaker.
It's hard producing a film.
But, like Mamie, we're proud
to say, "We're trying."
And I think it's really
going to come to fruition.
I think it's going to happen.
Anything else?
No?
>> Last question.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
Last question.
>> How come she cried
when the book came out?
>> Michelle Y. Green: She
cried out of gratitude.
She cried out of gratitude.
Someone had, finally,
written her story, and,
because of that book, I'm
so proud of that book.
Because nobody knew who
Mamie was, and now--
Her heart gave out on
her-- before she passed,
she has what's called
a "legacy."
Who knows what a legacy is?
>> When, like, a lot of
people know about you.
>> Michelle Y. Green: When a
lot of people know about you.
It's what you leave behind.
So, she knows that, even though
she may not be with us anymore,
her story is still being
enjoyed by people like you.
Something else that
happened with this book
that was really amazing.
Authors sometimes
get fan letters.
It's one of my favorite
thing to get a fan letter
in the mail or a Tweet.
I get Tweets now.
Yes, I Twitter.
I Facebook.
I Tumblr. I do all that stuff.
Some of the comments that I've
gotten are from women my age
and younger who said, "The
reason I love your book is
because I wanted to play
ball when I was little.
I wanted to play ball.
They wouldn't let me.
We played softball.
I wanted to play hardball,
and we weren't able to.
So, thank you very
much for showing us
that women can do
whatever they please
if they put their mind to it."
That and a little luck.
Let me just say this one
thing, because I know
that in the exhibit
someone mentioned
that the All-American
Girls League was there.
Uniforms? Well, Mamie tried
out for the All-American Girls.
She tried to.
It's in the book.
I won't tell you what happened.
Read it for yourself, but
she and her best friend went
down to the field-- Actually,
it was in Virginia-- to try out.
So, when the All-American
Girls were finally inducted
into Cooperstown-- That's where
all the baseball memorabilia
and baseball hall of fames
in Cooperstown, New York.
When they took the All-American
Girls and inducted them
into the Cooperstown Museum,
they invited Mamie to come.
What did Mamie say?
"No way. You didn't
want me then.
I don't want you
now" [laughter].
So, she didn't go be a
part of the grand opening
when they had the league of
their own team inducted there.
But there's some good news.
Ollie-- We call him
"Ollie Bug"--
took Evan, my baseball-playing
son to Cooperstown,
and I got this phone call.
They're selling A Strong Right
Arm in Cooperstown [laughs].
So, you see, Mamie got
her justice [inaudible].
Oh, that's it.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Thank
you very much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you all so much for coming
to the Library of Congress
for exploring Baseball
Americana and for listening
to our awesome author talk with
Michelle Y. Green [laughs].
How about we say "Thank you
for getting us all
a copy of the book"?
>> Michelle Y. Green: Yup.
>> Thank you.
>> Michelle Y. Green:
You're welcome.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Thanks,
everybody.